the new chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee is vowing to
investigate a bombshell new report about
the president according to a report by
BuzzFeed news president Trump quote
directed his longtime attorney Michael
Cohen to lie to Congress about
negotiations to build a Trump Tower in
Moscow the report cites two unnamed
federal law enforcement sources involved
in an investigation of the matter
Democratic Chairman Adam Schiff calls
the cover-up allegation among the most
serious to date we will do what's
necessary to find out if it's true Paula
Reid is at the White House good morning
Paula good morning John
back in November Cohen admitted that he
lied to Congress when he said those
trumped our talks ended in January 2016
when in fact they ended six months later
now BuzzFeed news is reporting that
Special Counsel Robert Muller has
uncovered evidence that the president
directed Cohen to lie to Congress
raising new questions about whether the
president sought to suborn perjury or
obstruct this investigation a bombshell
new report from BuzzFeed news claims
President Trump
personally instructed Cohen to lie to
Congress about the president's business
dealings in Moscow the revelations were
reportedly discovered during the special
counsels investigation into Russian
meddling in the 2016 election their
trump organization documents and
multiple interviews with witnesses Cohen
then will reportedly verify the
information in interviews with the
special counsel Cohen has previously
said he committed crimes for the
president out of loyalty
I gave loyalty to someone who truthfully
does not deserve loyal he was trying to
hide what you were doing correct correct
according to the BuzzFeed report two
unnamed federal law enforcement
officials say mr. Trump was also in
favor of making a trip to Russia during
the 2016 campaign to meet Russian
President Vladimir Putin personal I
don't know Putin have no business
whatsoever with Russia have nothing to
do with Russia during the campaign then
candidate Trump repeatedly denied having
any business dealings with Russia
he then backtracked those statements
last year
acquisition to possibly do a deal to
build a building of some kind in Moscow
I decided not to do it the primary
reason that could have been other
reasons but the primary reason it was
very simple I was focused on running for
president these revelations about
Cohen's testimony come just a day after
Cohen confirmed reports that the
president directed him to pay thousands
of dollars to a technology expert to rig
online polls in his favor
ahead of the 2016 campaign the president
has previously denied he directed Cohen
to commit any crimes we'll hear a lot
more from Cohen when he testifies before
Congress next month before heading to
prison in March to serve a three-year
sentence for campaign finance violations
we reached out to the president's
current personal attorney Rudy Giuliani
about this story and he told us quote if
you believe Cohen I can get you a great
deal on the Brooklyn Bridge Gail lose
the Brooklyn Bridge for sale thank you
very much Paula what's what's if this
report is right though what's important
about it is it's not based just on Cohen
it's based on documents and other people
and that's what makes this potentially
so dangerous for the president is
there's apparently other other evidence
not only documents but we also have him
on videotape all along the way
repeatedly denying what Michael Cohen is
now saying right it would be the first
example of Trump explicitly asking
someone to suborn perjury before
Congress that which raises the question
of impeachment right because Congress
tends to think if you tell someone to
lie to us it's the same as if you lie to
us yourself his testimony will be very
interesting next month and we'll all be
watching